what we covered bilinear interpolation
and nearest neighbor interpolation which
obviously see a lot of use in any kind
of imagery sampling but of course the
one we all use now is by cubic and I
kind of left that one hanging so let's
talk about how that works
thinking back to where we were before
we're looking at some pixel sidon and
what we're doing really is trying to
find some values in between where the
pixels are right because if we're
resizing an image when we're moving an
image for new locations we've got won't
necessarily match up with the previous
ones so if this is our image here so
these are my four actual pixels all
right nearest neighbor will just sample
between these pixels depending on which
one's nearest so it'll sort of go along
like this and then look at this like
that okay which is why you get me sort
of square pixelated edges a newest
neighbor that's very fast to do that and
as I said last time we haven't made up
any data doing that this is our sample
this stretches to here in some ways so
you know that's good
bilinear takes literally a linear
interpolation between these points so
it'll be like this and then this and
then this and maybe took off in this
direction depending on what the other
pixels are now this works fine sometimes
right but if we've got step changes or
weird areas of contrast changes and
funny shape so maybe this goes up and
then down suddenly this starts to look
not very smooth it's quite a jagged edge
you could find it sort of a little bit
like a sort of pyramid shape and might
look a bit ugly now we have to remember
that we're talking about between one or
two pixels so you know you've got to
zoom in a long way for this but on the
other hand if we can improve this why
wouldn't we what linear interpolation
does is take this value here this value
here and then find any of these
intermediate values you want depending
on how far along you are bicubic does
the exact same thing except it does it
in a much more smooth way and it does it
by knowing first of all where these two
points are and then two extra bits of
information which is what the
orientation or the gradient at these
positions are so if we know that the
gradient let's use my blue pen how about
that if we know that the gradient is
here and the gradient of this one is
sort of this direction we can kind of
come in like that and make it a bit
smoother so let's have a little look at
how that would work in an image what we
were actually fitting here is a sort of
piecewise cubic spline as
line is basically a small section of
curve that goes between two end points
right this one here will be a difference
blind to this one although very well
obviously join on in some sense splines
we used a lot of a time for 3d modeling
and things like this you get uniform
basis splines and things and Bezier
curves and how much splines they have
lots of different names they all do
similar things
so what we're fitting here is a third
degree polynomial equation right now
I'll draw out like the equation and then
we'll leave it there all right the
derivation of this math is not
absolutely complicated and we'll put a
link in the description that you can
follow along if you're that way inclined
but I'll try and talk a bit about more
the intuition of how it works so we've
got a value here at X naught we've got a
value here at X 1 and we're going
between X 0 and X 1 and the value of y
at this position is going to be some
polynomial that we have to find which is
a x cubed plus b x squared plus CX Plus
D there are 4 unknowns here X we know
because we're going between no 1 1 so
it's going to be some value between more
than one these four unknowns now given
the gradients at these locations or the
derivatives we can rearrange this
formula in a fairly convoluted way and
basically find out what ABC and D are so
what are ABC and D in this in this
equation well you have to look at the
formula they're based on a combination
of these positions and the derivatives
of these positions so for example C is
equal to X naught that's a simple
formula but they get more complicated
than that again follow the link in the
description if you want to know about
these things but the way it works is
that once we've rearranged the formula
we can find the position of any point
between these two points based on only
these two positions and the two tangents
so the question then remains how do we
calculate these two derivatives how do
we calculate the slope at these
positions that's fairly straightforward
on an image because we know what this
position is so intuitively if we're
going from here to here and then to
there it's going to be sort of some way
between the two right so in essence the
derivatives of a gradient at these
positions
depend on the next two pixels along so
unlike linear interpolation where we
only care about two points we now care
about the next two points outwards so
that we can get the gradients right so
if this position moves down here then
this is going to become more like this
and so this is going to come out more
and if this goes up here this is going
to be more like this and it's going to
be smoother so these two positions now
have a big impact on the shape of this
curve once we have this formula
extending it to two dimensional images
is exactly the same as the extension for
by linear interpolation so let me have a
look right if I take this off we had for
linear interpolation or by linear
interpolation we had four points here
and remember what we did to find out
what some other point was is we
interpolated between these two get our
intermediate points and then we
interpolate again the problem is just
extended so now we have 16 points all
the way along they're not very evenly
spaced we won't worry about that
I ran out of page so for this set of 16
points I missed one for this at a 16
point we're only now interpolating
within this small square in the middle
to do it with this one we'll have to
have more points over this in so we're
moving around what we do is we
interpolate this point here by using
these so maybe these have a curve like
this and maybe this has a curve like
this and this has a curve like this and
this has a curve like this and then we
get some points on here and finally we
can interpolate this smooth curve to get
our final interpolated point so all of
these 16 points are going to have an
effect and so it's going to look a lot
smoother and it can do more complex
shapes than linear interpolation can do
actual fact what we can do is we can
combine this sort of one dimension
followed by another dimension operation
into one matrix multiplication so it can
be very easily optimized and performed
very very quickly you can see that
derivation on the web of the world I
think I leave my photoshop setting to
Auto Joe is is it always going to pick
this though so I can't answer that
because I haven't seen the source code
for Photoshop but almost always so they
might be doing something clever there
are times when bicubic isn't strictly
better than bilinear it does some things
that you wouldn't expect so for example
if we have a sharp change in direction
so we have a pixel here
here so we're looking at the pixels from
the side again and so pixel here and
here and here right now bilinear
interpolation will sort of come along
here and draw a nice line like this
right which might be a bit jagged but
actually is broadly representative of
what this image does bicubic will
actually overshoot these two signals so
it will come in like this it'll probably
under suit here depending where the
other one is come up and go over these
signals and down like this now in some
ways that's smoother but actually that
is now brighter than these pixels worth
now maybe that's what the image did in
that position but I don't know we're
starting to make up a bit of data there
and also if these are at maximum
intensity we clip this so we have to go
on like well we can't go over to five
five in the RG and B so we'll just sort
of crop it there and get rid of that
right which is not ideal we do it here
as well mmm so it isn't always ideal now
in most images you aren't using
necessarily the full range all at a time
you're not going between nought and 255
all the time sharply so this hardly ever
comes up in images and which is why it
looks good but it might and if you've
got a sharp change stop step change in a
sense 'ti you're going to see a little
bit of overshoot possibly just beyond
your edge which you won't necessarily
want right so if you see if you have
black to white or dark grey to light
gray and you see a little bit of a peak
you know what it is
right that's what bye-bye bicubic will
do remember we're again we're talking
about single pixels zoomed right in so
maybe you know only specific special
images that you can't really test it
might might show these problems but they
are there and they are something to bear
in mind it's very difficult for a
firewall or something to notice this
because these are valid HTTP requests
they're just super slow alright and you
know maybe I've just got really bad
internet connection maybe yeah now this
doesn't affect every web server it
mostly affects Apache